>> Stephen: WELCOME TO THE
REPORT, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> STEPHEN!
STEPHEN!
STEPHEN.
>> Stephen: THANK YOU SO
MUCH, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE'VE GOT
TO-- FOLKS, I GOTTA TELL YOU,
ONE QUICK THING, ONE QUICK
THING.
I KNOW WE'VE GOT A BIG SHOW TO
DO TONIGHT, BUT ONE THING BEFORE
WE GET STARTED, THERE WAS SOME
BIG NEWS LAST WEEK THAT SLIPPED
THROUGH MY NEWS CRACK, AND IT
CONCERNS SOMEONE I'VE ADMIRED
FOR YEARS, AND YET SURPRISINGLY
IS NOT ME.
I'M TALKING ABOUT DAVID
LETTERMAN, WHO LAST THURSDAY
NIGHT ANNOUNCED HIS RETIREMENT.
AND I AM GOING TO MISS THIS GOOD
MAN.
DAVE HAS BEEN ON THE AIR MY
ENTIRE ADULT LIFE, "LATE NIGHT"
DEBUTED MY FIRST YEAR IN
COLLEGE.
I LEARNED MORE FROM WATCHING
DAVE THAN I DID FROM GOING TO MY
CLASSES.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
ESPECIALLY-- ESPECIALLY THE ONES
I DID NOT GO TO BECAUSE I HAD
STAYED UP UNTIL 1:30 WATCHING
DAVE.
( APPLAUSE )
THIS MAN HAS INFLUENCED EVERY
HOST WHO CAME AFTER HIM, AND
EVEN A FEW WHO CAME BEFORE HIM.
HE'S THAT GOOD.
( LAUGHTER )
AND I GOTTA TELL YOU, I DO NOT
ENVY WHOEVER THEY TRY TO PUT IN
THAT CHAIR.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> STEPHEN!
STEPHEN!
STEPHEN!>> Stephen: FOLKS, FOLKS,
THOSE ARE SOME HUGE SHOES TO
FILL, AND SOME REALLY BIG PANTS.